[Musique]
ma fille mon enfant je vois venir le
temps où tu vas me quitter pour changer
de saison pour changer de maison pour
changer
d'habitude j'y pense chaque soir en
guettant du regard ton enfance qui joue
à rompre les Amar et me laisse le
goût d'un accord de
guitare tu as tant voyagé moi de mon
côté j'étais souvent parti de l'Inde à
l'Angleterre on a couru la terre et pas
toujours ensemble mais à chaque retour
nos mains se rejoignaient sur le de de
velour d'un chien qui nous aimait
c'était notre
façon d'être bon
compagnon mon enfant
mon
petit bonne route bonne
route sur le chemin de la
vie nos deux cœurs vont changer le
Pays Ma fille tu as 20 ans et j'attends
le moment du premier
rendez-vous que tu me donneras chez toi
ou bien chez moi ou sur une
terrasse où nous évoquerons un rire au
coin des yeux le chien ou le poisson qui
partageit nos jeux où nous
frudonnerons les mots de nos
chansons à vivre sous mon toit il me
semble que toi que l'on c'était
perdu je vais te retrouver je vais me
retrouver dans chacun de tes gestes on
sait qui tes parents on se retrouve ami
ce sera mieux qu'avant je n'auraai pas
vieilli je viendrai simplement
partager tes 20
ans mon
enfant mon
petit bonne route bonne route sur le
chemin de la vie nos deux cœurs vont
changer le
[Musique]
pays
[Applaudissements]